what a way for Oracle to close down what
a way for the season to end and one away
for the draft and the free agency period
to be set up and on all of that from the
world wide leader in sports man has been
covering the NBA for a decade plus
joining me here right back on the Rich
Eisen show Dave McMenamin how are you
Dave I'm well I feel like I spent so
much emotion watching last night's game
it was such a great one and also in a
way a cruel one to see klay Thompson go
down like that
in the midst of just a brilliant effort
to try to force a game seven that after
we already saw what happened to KD in
Game five and I wanted more basketball
but I guess we got to take some time off
to let these guys heal before next
season yeah and and Dave I mean the the
narrative that we've been talking about
all year long can the can the Warriors
three-peat and then the July first date
that was looming throughout the entire
season and the question about how the
playoffs would actually feed into July
first and what it would mean for the
free agency period and now Durant and
klay Thompson appear to be out for the
next season as we're just a few weeks
from July first how does this all affect
the dominoes of free agency Dave I think
the biggest question is will the
Warriors want to offer to max contracts
to two guys who will miss an entire
season out of those max contracts you
can do it with one we've seen it before
you know the the Lakers did it with Kobe
Bryant the Wizards did it with Gilbert
Arenas knowing that going into that
season that guy's not gonna play but you
still want that player to do with to is
unprecedented I just don't know where
that's gonna go and it becomes the
question of okay well then well one of
those guys go elsewhere and of course no
one was really assuming that Kevin
Durant would be returning to the
Warriors you know there's obviously been
a lot of smoke around him going the
going out to the the Knicks or you know
you can talk about the Nets but I just
most curious right now because this is
the sample size that we have we saw the
reactions of the team officials walking
through to the back with both those guys
in games five and Game six
what will the Warriors actually do what
will the Warriors actually do what will
the Knicks do if they might try and
offer Durant a max knowing that he's not
around for a full year I know the Lakers
were interested in klay Thompson as were
a bunch of other teams but I want to put
a pin in that for just a for just a
brief second because when you you you
look at the landscape of July first with
these guys potentially being out you
have to wonder if the Rockets now when
the word coming from folks in in the
information business that everybody was
up for trade and Daryl Morey was
thinking of maybe redoing the team if he
could why not just keep everything as is
knowing that the Warriors aren't going
to be who they've been Dave right yeah
it's a wonderful point and to be honest
I understand that daryl morey is a guy
who never rest on his laurels and is
innovative and they're always trying to
find ways to improve in the margins but
I was a little surprised by that story
to begin with the fact that you know
basically anyone but James Harden would
be expendable in trying to fix that team
you they've been a really really good
basketball team that ran into the Golden
State bus two straight years they have
to feel as good as anybody right now
based on the contracts they have on
their books and the success they've
already had as we look for it now three
weeks from now as we see free agents go
different places that conversation could
certainly change but but right now if
you were to pick one favorite you know
they would probably be there right with
Toronto but the thing with Toronto you
don't know Kawhi Leonard's gonna be on
the team next year and so perhaps if you
were to pick one favor in this moment
based on certainty
of thought it would be the Houston
Rockets Dave McMenamin here on the Rich
Eisen show okay and the first blush
thought about Kauai where he's going the
question was always what would it be
more likely for him to leave with a win
or a loss now we know it is a win what
do you think what are the winds sounding
like because last night when Kauai was
asked about the win for Toronto and the
city in the country he said it's
something that they can build off of he
referred to it as they not we what do
you think Dave yeah and also struck me
that when he was talking about getting
traded there the summer before he kind
of made it sound like he had just
finished the goal that he was looking to
accomplish and and if that is you know a
finished type of feeling that he has
that would make it easier for him to
move on like you know he didn't choose
to go to Toronto but he made it sound
like in his head he was like okay well
best case scenario let's let's just win
a chip and then I'm free to do whatever
the heck I want to do because again he
didn't choose to go to Toronto and so
certainly well aware that you know
speaking to the Clippers officials
throughout the year that has been their
plan one plan one a one B plan I won't
see it is to go after Kawhi Leonard and
the SoCal roots are well reported that
has to be in my mind still an option a
very least I surely believe he's gonna
be taking free agency meetings but
Toronto should have a pretty good case
to present them as well we'll see if
that GM Masai Ujiri will be the guy
presenting the case with the Washington
Wizards they're trying to pry him away
and it's toll it's it's totally nuts I
mean we could literally go in 50
different directions based on the number
of free agents available the number of
teams Milwaukee included that could be
ravaged by free agency or retain
everybody and it could be in just a few
weeks that Doc Rivers is absolutely free
to compare Kawhi Leonard to Michael
Jordan and not be fine for it I
so the one way I want to go with you
however Dave McMenamin here from ESPN is
the Anthony Davis scenario and the
Lakers and what is going on with them
and to start that I want you to
reiterate you you are the one who LeBron
said something about Anthony Davis to
many moons ago feels like years ago but
it was just months ago that sparked the
whole clutch sports rich Paul LeBron
James bring Anthony Davis to the Lakers
scenario Dave walk me through that story
you told here in studio to set up this
conversation if you don't mind please
write this was back in December and it
was before a game that the Nets played
against the Lakers at Barclays Center
and I had just done a Sports Center hit
on the court and the part of the hit was
was were talking about Anthony Davis how
he was going to be making his first trip
to Staples Center later that week to
play against the Lakers first trip of
the season of course and as I was doing
my television hit it was airing in the
locker room I guess LeBron and others
were watching it and I went into the
locker room after you in my head that I
normally do to talk to the players
during availability and LeBron kind of
looked at me with look kind of like a
you know something I don't know like
what are you talking about ad for and I
you know I just kind of said well you
know he's coming to town and you know
there's speculation you might not want
to finish his career or resign in New
Orleans and you know obviously Lakers
would be a team looking to improve and
he's you know and then of course he said
to me the quote that was referenced a
lot throughout last season was that it
died would be amazing it would be
incredible if a Lakers traded for him
with some people viewed as LeBron
throwing his teammates under the bus
because it would resolve them needing to
be going away from LA to make it happen
other people though it was the most
obvious code of all time of of course do
you want to trade for a top seven player
in his prime in Nancy Davis and and now
here we stand the Lakers have
re-involved themselves in the Anthony
Davis sweepstakes and there's appears to
be a shortlist of teams that are vying
for services I mean you have basically
built eaves we've heard of so far I've
been the Lakers the Celtics and the
Knicks you wonder why the Clippers
you don't hear as much about them and
maybe it's because they they're their
sights are set on Kawhi Leonard until
told that they can't get them but but
this is really will be when we just
talked about the power structure the NBA
and then you know should the Rockets be
the favorite going in the next year or
you know you mentioned the Bucs that's
another team yet to talk about - you
know wherever Andy Davis that's up that
team very likely it will be in the the
short list of contenders for next year
well I mean and then you asked LeBron if
you could go on the record with his
quote and he gave you the right to do
that and then that started a whole
firestorm and then comes the public
statement or the made it public that
that Anthony Davis wanted to get traded
something that rich Paul told Sports
Illustrated this week was Dell Demps
trying to sabotage things and so so my
question is is do you think that this
has been a plan for LeBron and rich Paul
and clutch sports and Anthony Davis from
the minute that it seemed like he just
said something to you off the cuff
Dave and that this is inevitable well I
reported last year that last summer when
LeBron met with Matt Johnson Andy Davis
his name did not come up before he
signed with the Lakers so it was a plan
it doesn't root itself all the way back
whatever that would be eleven months ago
but yeah I certain believe even though
he made an off-the-cuff comment to me in
December that comment was preceded by
you know whatever conversation
LeBron would have had with his
management team as he canvassed the
league and
thought about ways the team can get
better where where do things stand right
now right now you know agent Romanoff
you bleeding are our coverage and there
still seems to be the issue and I'm not
even sure this is fair to characterize
the hang-up issue because you know it
could very well be just New Orleans
that's waiting for other offers to pour
in but the Lakers offer of Brandon
Ingram
Lonzo ball the number four pick does not
include Cal Kuzma and that according to
the reporting by eight.hoorah ski and
others that is a piece that New Orleans
covets and far the Lakers are reticence
included because they feel like they
have more leverage than the team they're
vying against currently in the Boston
Celtics because you mentioned rich Paul
reached old Sports Illustrated in no
uncertain terms that Anthony Davis will
not be extending and residing there next
summer and so is Boston really gonna
make that great of an offer if they know
it's a one-year rental and hence the
Lakers are trying to hold on
and not make that Godfather offer
because they feel like they are in the
driver's seat
yeah but the board of the Lakers need a
game-changer they they cannot walk away
from July 1st striking out and klay
Thompson is not walking through that
door with a with an ACL I mean they
can't max out somebody that can't play
for one of the remaining three years or
even two years of LeBrons window there
they can't do that yeah the same you
can't you can't even consider going out
decade in your class your time frame
doesn't allow it even if one of them
told you I'd love to come but you go I
meant in a different reality that would
be fun but they can't right and so you
know obviously the names and this was
Magic Johnson said on first take the two
names that he believed they should
target our Kyrie Irving and Kawhi
Leonard and and very well that could
still be the case but the pairing one of
those two
with LeBron and AD and now you're
talking about not just being the Lakers
being in the conversation as a contender
but very well being the saver last
minute here with Dave McMenamin of ESPN
joining me here and we've got Charles
Barkley coming up in the next hour to
talk about last night's game so the
draft is six days away
it's Zion is there any shot that morant
doesn't go to Barrett goes to Marant
drops to the Knicks well what are you
hearing for any potential surprises at
the top of that draft Dave I would be
very surprised if it wasn't one as I am
to camera and based on what we've heard
from RJ Berry's you know he wants to be
in New York and then sometimes that
manifest destiny seems to go a long way
as we saw the case with Lonzo ball and
the Lakers a couple of years ago
beyond that I'm not gonna make many
predictions because you hear a lot about
Terry Culver you hear about DeAndre
hunter you hear about Tyrus garland you
know Daris garland again another clutch
quiet only played four games for
Vanderbilt last year but considered to
have a Steph Curry Kyrie Irving type of
game and you know could be the steal of
the draft but he's not really working
out for teams and so teams don't have a
lot to go on so I I'm I I feel like it
will be somewhat shock based on the
draft boards that we see one through
three but beyond that stuff crazy new
stuff could absolutely get crazy and
then the Lakers you think more likely
than not don't choose that don't keep
where they choose it for or don't choose
it for at all yes or no what do you
think right now I'm not so sure it's
ready gets done prior to the draft I
think their intention though would not
to be shooting at all you know just like
they can't sign a guy who's hurt to help
them next year even a top-flight
prospect we saw it with their young
players last year to rely on that young
of a player to help them for what
they're trying to altum Utley achieve
I don't think that's the route either
okay and then the the odds that the
Knicks max out Durant no matter what
because that's what I'm hearing from all
my Nick friend saying just go ahead and
do it
bring him in max him out what do you
think do you think someone else I think
does I think the I think they're gonna
shoot their shot
I couldn't imagine them not doing it and
I understand he'll be close to 32 but
the next time he's fully healthy but
he's still Kevin Graham and yeah I I
can't imagine that be like you know what
yeah actually really like Kevin Knox I
think they gotta make a play for Dave
thanks Lee call really appreciate your
your time coming in studio making some
phone calls expect our phone call over
the next couple weeks to with free
agency hidden okay thank right you got
Dave McMenamin of ESPN at MC 10 on
Twitter right here on the Rich Eisen
show for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR Live or download the Rich
Eisen show app